all right
Kyle's with us in Kentucky hey Kyle how
are you doing today
better than I deserve what's up so I'm
I'm 41 and I'm starting I'm wanting to
stay out of it of course so I'm trying
I'm not out of that I still had that of
course and I'm trying to get my wife I'm
smaller side bass Beth I'm trying to
have a wife become with me and do with
me cuz all I want to do with myself I
feel like I can work on myself
I got a budget like a filibuster on
Google sheets out and I looked at the
past three months on I'm ready at that
part I just need to figure out a way to
get her on and I can't get her on
without like you know just being like I
want that you know that's not another
well thought of amusing problem is
you're being a guy and let me tell you
what guys do me too we always
immediately go to fixing the problem and
here's what we got to do we get on a
budget and we got to do this and we got
to sell this and we gotta work extra and
know we can't go out to eat anymore
and you start talking about what to do
that's what guys always do what do we do
we're gonna fix this what are we gonna
do what are we gonna do meanwhile she's
standing there going no thanks
I don't wanna play and so what you
should do is apologize to her for doing
that and then say you know what we
really should be talking about is why I
want to do this and why as a couple we
should want to win financially I really
am honey I've been reading this stuff
I've been looking at this stuff on
YouTube and I've really come to the
conclusion that if we were to work
together we could become very wealthy
and that would change our family tree
for our kids that would allow us to
retire with dignity allow us to be more
generous allow us to travel allow us to
get out of this dumpy but car and get a
nice one whatever it is okay I don't
know what her dream is but if you gave
her a million dollars what she would
shoot what would she do with it that's
your why that's why we're doing this and
then if she says okay and then I'd like
to have a million dollars so I could do
X or I could do Y or I could do Z that's
your Y
you say all right now how are we gonna
get there when we were gonna get there
gonna get on a budget we're gonna get
out of debt we're gonna stay out of debt
we're gonna invest and we're gonna work
on this together because all the data
points say the couples that work
together have a very high probability of
building wealth and almost no couples
that don't work together become wealthy
highly unusual for a married couple to
become wealthy when they're not working
together right so also like I get that
work so I appreciate that a lot
like also so she has she's graduating
college next semester great and then
we'll be going full-time great doing
what she's doing and should we merge our
bank accounts in or should we go ahead
do it now you should do it now you're
married they should be married they
should be merged the rest of your life
and you should merge your goals and your
dreams because you are now one the
preacher said when you walk down the
aisle he didn't say and now I pronounce
you a joint-venture you are now one
that's why couples that work together
are the ones that are able to build well
and that's what we push you to do hold
on I'm gonna tell Kelly to sign you guys
up we're gonna put you into Financial
Peace University the one-year membership
it's gonna include every dollar the foot
world's best budgeting app it's gonna
include the nine week class it's gonna
include everything I'm gonna give it all
to you get you started I wish somebody
done that when I was 21